Speaker 1: Former President Barack Obama was
out campaigning for a number of different
2022 candidates.
He was in Georgia, he was in Michigan.
He was elsewhere as well, I believe.
And I have to tell you that it was extraordinarily
refreshing.
Now, I know some of you will say hell, but
David, you neoliberal liberal shill Barack
Obama used drone warfare and I would be with
you 100%.
And I was critical of that when it was going
on.
But generally speaking, Barack Obama made
clear that there is one party right now that
believes in democracy, period, no matter what
the outcome is, whereas the other party, the
Republican Party, sort of believes in it if
they win.
But if not, then they believe in something
very different than democracy.
He spoke passionately.
He absolutely crushed all of the Republicans
that were running in those states.
And I don't want to waste any time.
Let's get right into the first clip.
Here is Barack Obama on Social Security.
This was in Milwaukee, Wisconsin, campaigning
against Ron Johnson for Mandela.
Barnes a very important race is.
Speaker 5: Some of you here are on Social
Security.
Some of your parents are on Social Security.
Some of your grandparents are on Social Security.
You know why they have Social Security?
Because they worked for it.
Unidentified: They worked hard jobs for.
They had checked hands for their.
Speaker 5: Nose and sore backs and bad knees
to get that Social Security.
And if Ron Johnson does not understand that.
If he understands giving tax breaks for private
planes more than he understands making sure
that seniors who worked all their lives able
to retire with dignity and respect.
He's not the person who's thinking about you
and knows you and sees you.
Unidentified: And he should not be your senator
from Wisconsin.
Speaker 1: Every single one of this weekend
speeches was this level of energy and also
this accurate about what it is that these
Republicans want to do.
Here's another brilliant one from Detroit,
Michigan.
Speaker 5: The other day.
I did not realize this.
I did not.
I read about this.
Somebody had to show it to me.
The other day, a video came out of Governor
Whitmer's opponent claiming that Democrats
have been working for decades to topple.
The United States because they're still upset
about losing the Civil War.
And the Coleman restrictions were part of
some master plan to do this now.
First of all, what?
What?
I mean, I know some folks go down these rabbit
holes on the Internet, they're up to late,
but that's like a subway tunnel.
That's that's deep.
Speaker 1: And that is indeed the way it works.
They go down absolutely bonkers conspiracy
theories now.
Then he was also in Georgia in support of
Raphael Warnock against Herschel Walker, where,
by the way, the polling is looking increasingly
disastrous for Raphael Warnock.
But we'll cover that momentarily.
And Barack Obama making the case.
Herschel Walker, fine football player.
But, Senator, that doesn't make any sense.
Speaker 5: Some of you may not remember, but
Herschel Walker was a heck of a football player.
I mean I mean, some of you are too young to
remember, but in college, he was amazing.
One of the best.
Running backs of all to.
But but but here's the question.
Does that make him the best person to represent
you in the USA?
Does that make him equipped to weigh in on
the critical decisions about our economy and
our foreign policy and our future?
But let's do a thought experiment.
Let's say you're at the airport.
And you see, Mr. Walker, you say, hey, there's
Herschel Walker, Heisman winner.
Let's have him fly the plane.
Unidentified: You probably wouldn't say that.
Speaker 1: No, you would not.
And indeed, saying that he should be one of
100 members of the Senate making such important
decisions is insanity.
And sadly, that's what's going on.
Barack Obama making the point that House Republicans
are ready and willing to impeach Joe Biden.
They don't even really know why.
Speaker 5: A record.
If they get control of Congress, they will
spend the next two years investigating President
Biden and their political opponents.
That's all they want to do.
They see it as payback.
Now that some are, some of them said that
they are they've already got prepared that
they're going to impeach Biden.
They're not sure what for.
But apparently that's beside the point.
And you're laughing.
Except they've actually said it.
They have literally said, we're not sure what
the theory is, but we've got to come up with
one.
Speaker 1: In fact, there's an incredible
clip from I believe it was a New Hampshire
debate, which I played for you, where they
were going around saying, what would you impeach
Joe Biden for?
And everybody agreed they should impeach Biden
other than one candidate.
But they disagreed as to why they should impeach
him.
And they have absolutely no idea in reality.
Barack Obama also making the point that no
matter what's going on out there, even an
asteroid heading towards Earth, they want
tax cuts for the rich and they do.
Speaker 5: The Republicans are having a field
day running ads talking about it.
But what is their actual solution to it?
Unidentified: Well, I'll tell you.
They want to.
Speaker 5: Cut Social Security and Medicare
and then give some more tax breaks to the
wealthy.
And the reason the reason I know that's their
agenda is, listen, that their answer to everything.
When inflation is low.
What do you want to do?
Cut taxes when unemployment's all where you
want.
Let's cut taxes on the wealthy.
That's going to solve that.
I was joking down in Georgia if there was
an asteroid headed towards Earth.
Is going in in like two weeks.
If you went in the Republican Congress and
you said, what do you want to do?
Well, we need a tax break for the wealthy.
Unidentified: That's going to help.
I am only barely exaggerating.
Speaker 1: I don't even know that he is exaggerating.
I think if there were such an asteroid, Republicans
would say, well, let's, I guess, do something
about the asteroid.
But let's remember, once we survive the asteroid,
we need to encourage business growth.
And the way to do that is give a tax cut to
the rich.
I don't think it's an exaggeration whatsoever.
Barack Obama accurately pointing out that
there are two obsessions for Republicans right
now owning the libs and getting Donald Trump's
approval.
Speaker 5: This hasn't always been a partizan
thing.
My favorite president was a guy from my home
state of Illinois named Abe Lincoln.
Help found the Republican Party.
It used to be that there were GOP members
who championed progress and civil rights and
rule of law.
Folks who who were with me in the 2008 election.
You remember we talked about bringing people
together and and spoke to all people, regardless
of party, about how we could move the country
forward.
So so that's my instinct.
I'm not some body who believes that all that
some party label defines us.
But but I have to speak the truth, which is
these days, just about every Republican politician
seems obsessed with just two things on the
lips and less on the lips.
And.
And getting Donald Trump's approval.
That's their agenda.
No, no, no.
Don't boo.
Speaker 1: Vote.
Yeah, he does warn Barack Obama.
Does Mandela Barnes?
You'd better be ready with that birth certificate,
my friend.
Speaker 5: I want to say something here.
I know that there's some folks, maybe not
in this auditorium, but elsewhere in Wisconsin
who think and I know these ads are running
this way.
But just because Mandela's name Mandela.
Just because he's a Democrat with a with a
funny name.
He must not be like you.
He must not share your values.
I mean, we've seen this.
It sounds pretty familiar, doesn't it?
So.
So, Mandela, get ready to take up that first
ticket.
Get ready.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Love him or hate him on his politics.
Former President Obama is very, very good
at this.
Now, will it be enough to turn around some
of these races?
I wish I could say yes.
Let's take a look at some of the latest polling